Hello.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Paul Saxman, a developer
advocate on the Google Maps API
team.
In this video, I
cover the basics
of adding markers to a map using
the Google Maps Android API V2.
Markers are the fundamental way
to show position of something
on a map.
Something in this context can
be a place, such as a city
venue or landmark, or it could
be a transient or moving object
such as a person or vehicle.
Essentially, markers can be
used to represent anything
that has a global position
in latitude and longitude
coordinates.
Adding a marker to the map is
as simple as calling addMarker
on the Google Map object
with a marker options
object as a parameter.
An instance of a marker
is returned from addMarker
so that you can later
update or remove the marker.
You can remove a map marker
by calling the remove method
on the marker instance.
When creating a marker,
the marker options object
needs to be configured
with a position in lat
long coordinates,
but it also supports
a number of other
optional parameters.
For example, you can
create an invisible marker,
which you can
later make visible.
Or you can set the
transparency for a marker
using the alpha property.
The default marker is a
red inverted tear drop,
which should be
familiar to most users.
However, you can easily
change the color of a marker
or provide your own marker
image using the icon
method and a bitmap
descriptor factory object.
We'll cover these
techniques in a video
on creating custom
markers, however,
since there are a
number of ways that you
can change a
marker's appearance.
After a marker has
been created, most
of its properties like its
position, visibility, and icon
can be changed by calling
corresponding mutator
methods on the marker class.
For example, if
you want to toggle
the visibility of
a marker, you can
call a setVisible method
of a marker instance.
Toggling marker
visibility is a great way
to implement place
filtering, since making
an initially invisible
marker visible
is faster than creating
a new marker altogether.
For example, if you want to
allow the user to hide or show
hotels with specific
price or cost levels,
you'll likely want to use marker
visibility instead of creating
new markers altogether to
get the best performance.
If you want to show a
small amount of information
on the map along
with the marker,
you can add a title and
snippet to your marker using
the corresponding methods
on the marker options class.
The title and
snippet are displayed
in an info window, a
bubble over the marker when
the user touches the marker.
You can also programmatically
show or hide the info window
using the showInfoWindow
and hideInfoWindow
methods of a marker instance.
You can fully customize
the appearance
of the info window using
an info window adapter.
However, since there
are a couple ways
that you can customize
an info window,
we'll cover these techniques
in a separate video as well.
If you want to take some other
action when a user touches
a marker besides
showing an info window,
you can implement an
on-marker click listener
and assign an instance
of your listener
to the Google Map class.
When a user touches the marker,
the on-marker click method
of your adapter instance
is called with a reference
to the marker that was clicked.
It can therefore be useful to
maintain a hash map of markers
that you've created in order
to look up and display more
information about the
place or object associated
with a marker.
For example, if you use
markers to represent hotels
and you want to show
details about a hotel
in a separate view when a
user touches a hotel marker,
you can use a hash map to look
up the hotel description using
a clicked marker as the key.
So now you should know how
to get started with markers.
If you'd like more information,
check out our documentation
and watch a show
about custom markers.
In the meantime, have fun
making remarkable maps.
Thanks for joining and
hope to see you soon.